the fight over Anne heche's estate
enters a new chapter but home or no he's
a businessman he's going to run my
business for me some days a judge ruled
her 20-year-old son Homer laffoon can be
in charge of her estate for now and
according to court documents obtained by
E.T last week at the time of her death
in August Anne's net worth was four
hundred thousand dollars
this comes amid Homer's ongoing Court
battle over control of his late mother's
assets on the other side James Tupper
Anne's ex and father to their 13 year
old son Atlas I'm so lucky I do I walk
around with a joyous experience I have
two beautiful children a judge already
ruled Anne's estate will be split 50 50
between Homer and Atlas and James wants
a third party to oversee the process but
a judge grants it Homer's request to be
administrator of Anne's estate for the
time being they are the most incredible
kids while Homer didn't attend the
hearing in person on Tuesday James was
seen shaking his head in court following
the ruling getting an earful from the
judge for the public display there's
this saying let go and let God
and that's kind of how I live my life
also in the court filings Anne was
living in an apartment when she died
following her horrific car crash
what's the emergency there
a car just went through my neighbor's
house and the 400 000 the Homer says
it's from a quote few modest bank
accounts royalty payments and a stake in
her Better Together podcast whenever
you're telling a story like this you
have to relive it and I think that was
not something that I was expecting
necessarily there's also future profits
from her second Memoir call me in due
out next year hopefully I can just give
the truth you know
I think if I had had the truth given to
me when I was a kid things would have
been different so I hope I can give the
truth as James tells it he's worried
about the brother's relationship and
claimed homers made it difficult for
them to enter Ann's apartment which
Homer's legal team denies I like life
that's what it is Anna was cremated at
Hollywood Forever Cemetery her final
resting place I also like acting in all
different kinds of things home run Atlas
said in a joint statement quote we are
convinced our mom would love the sight
we have chosen for her it's beautiful
Serene and she will be among her
Hollywood peers I would say to anybody
you know go for what you feel truthfully
in your life and you will be rewarded a
million fold the sun's added quote she
was our mom but the kindness and the
outpouring of the past few days reminded
us that she also belongs to her fans to
the entertainment community and now to
the ages
foreign